[Musique]
pour ou contre le réchauffement de la
planète au moment des vacances j'aime
bien
est-ce que vous êtes Franck Dubosc pour
ou contre les trentenaires qui chantent
l'île aux enfants des soirées privées
pour
bien sûr voici venu le temps je ne suis
pas trop clair
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
année difficile aussi Franck parce que
c'est l'année où vous avez perdu votre
votre père oui ma vue réussir mais il a
il a
j'ai du mal à parler de ça alors
il a pas vu l'Olympia donc ça ça vous
avez des réactions de Lionel Jospin non
finalement apprécier Lionel Jospin en
fait dans toute cette histoire c'est vos
allusions la taille de son sexe
qu'est-ce que tu veux dire par un peu
court pour être président
le matin quand tu te regardes dans la
glace est-ce que tu te dis ouais cool je
suis David Hallyday
non
non je me dis pas ça non je me dis que
j'aurais mieux fait de dormir 2h de plus
j'ai pas été
nickel tout va bien moi j'ai quand même
appris que Johnny Hallyday était ton
père
est-ce que vous avez décidé d'arrêter
les émissions de télé à la con
bon moi je suis ici ce soir donc
non
en fait je pars du principe que je n'ai
pas aimé les homosexuels et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi c'est pour moi les
homosexuels n'existent pas exactement
comme les hétérosexuels n'existent pas
je considère qu'il y a une sexualité par
personne que la communauté homosexuelle
c'est quelque chose qui m'échappe comme
si par exemple on faisait une communauté
des mecs à lunettes blond avec des
doubles foyers qui mettent des baskets
ADIDAS
et il a piqué ton business hein
est-ce qu'il y a des sosies de Johnny
Hallyday beaucoup non oui je connais
assez Johnny Hallyday qui m'a dit une
phrase inoubliable il m'a dit je suis
bien content que Johnny ce soit
stabilisé sentimentalement parce que
j'arrivais plus à suivre
du second excusez-moi 2 secondes
vraiment c'est presque fini excusez-moi
pardon excusez-moi Thierry Ardisson
bonsoir excusez-moi de d'interrompre
l'enregistrement des missions je suis
vraiment désolé la télévision vous a
apporté la gloire le pouvoir l'argent la
réussite
duquel vous vous débarrasseriez le plus
facilement aujourd'hui donc
ça rend pas mégalo comme ça de harenguer
des des foules de plusieurs milliers de
personnes avec la voix booster avec son
image sur des écrans géants c'est
totalement c'est une c'est une drogue
dure mais en même temps comme c'est le
métier que j'avais choisi c'est à peu
près le seul truc que je sais faire et
puis ça me rapporte beaucoup de pognon
j'ai du mal à renoncer de l'autre côté
2 ans de travail
500 candidats au départ 500 ce qui fait
100 nichons bienvenue
c'est la Techno Parade de Jack Lang
c'est encore plus chiant que la fête des
mères c'est absolument
Jack Lang combien y aurait-il de Gay
Pride par an
mais peut-être qu'il y en aurait plus
aucune puisque finalement nous aurions
profondément transformé les leurs la vie
serait une énorme Gay Pride
l'abeille se fait tirer en plein vol
pendant deux jours par une cinquantaine
de mâles et d'ailleurs le mal il tire et
il laisse les les couilles et la
sur le truc d'ailleurs tire et il meurt
il tire son cou en plein vol comme un
vulgaire Stewart
un mec décidé qui a décidé de donner sa
vie vaut une armée entière cette guerre
ne peut pas être gagnée on peut pas les
Américains ont compris qui se faisaient
descendre les deux tours de World Trade
Center avec 12 mecs décidés et quatre
cutter il y a des parents qui éduquent
leurs enfants leur disant si tu te fais
péter la gueule en tuant d'autres
personnes tu seras un héros et ne me
dites pas que ça peut pas arriver parce
que c'est ce qui se passe ce gosse de 17
ans il y a des gens qui donnent de
l'argent à sa famille il y a des gens
qui lui donnent la ceinture de bombe
ces gens-là ont des noms ce sont des
organisations certaines basées en Arabie
Saoudite ce sont des états la Syrie
l'Irak ce sont une partie des dirigeants
palestiniens c'est l'autorité
palestinienne elle-même qui a détourné
le fric de l'aide humanitaire le fric de
la Communauté européenne pour pour
fanatiser des gaz
je baise les pieds de tous les
pacifistes du monde entier à contre a
commencé par les Israéliens et les
Américains parce que faut avoir une
sacrée paire de couilles pour être
pacifiste en Israël et je leur baise les
pieds et je leur dis merci d'exister et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu